All right, so here I have written out
3 JavaScript elements.
Number 1, a function definition of a function mymin,
given 2 arguments a and b, if a is less than b we return a.
Otherwise we return b. We're returning whichever one is smaller.
Over here, another function definition for a function called "square."
It takes in a variable x and returns x times x.
And then over here, number 3, a statement.
We're calling write, or if you prefer, document.write,
to display the result of calling mymin on the square of -2 and the square of 3.
In essence what we're trying to figure out is which is smaller,
-2 squared or 3 squared?
And then we're going to print out that result.
Your mission, should you choose to accept it,
translate this to Python.
Submit via the interpreter.
Write a Python program that does exactly the same as this JavaScript.